[Music]
huh
okay
you
today's subway shooting in brooklyn
happening not far from where the raptors
will practice
floor preparing for tonight's play-in
game against cleveland when the fallout
from another act of gun violence became
an all-time familiar reality
many of the nets were arriving or had
already arrived
ridership
coming up here
is
so
like
skinny as [ __ ]
[Music]
sleep
um
what am i looking at
joey you're looking that way you're
looking at your two o'clock
straight down the street two o'clock
that one
right
right now
my
okay
you already
three times
they don't know that good looking
yes
see if
entirely
across the line
i'd also like to make the point
is
c2
classic 1970s
oh
five
right
is
i don't know
foreign
hey
brendan just told me to ask
eduardo hey
that uh there's an active helicopter on
a citizen that's been looking at it this
whole time are they looking at the same
one
he just sent me the link on citizen i
can send it to you i can't view it
because i didn't have citizen loaded
he sent me something
they're looking at the helicopter
boys
well they do have to refuel
somebody just like oh there's a uh
eduardo is walking fast with intention
are you just walking really quickly
usually when you do that things get
exciting
guys
i said okay
um
you think the bomb squad would have
already
if my subaru can get through traffic
you saw it joe yeah
how early did you get here dude
like 10 minutes
yes
yes
three people
foreign
okay
so
hey
foreign
happiness
okay
almost
maybe not
all right
okay
hello
since i am
like
i'm not usually
right
so they're going off of a receipt they
found out
like that
i mean the tip-off is when they didn't
have that second press when they had it
scheduled oh he's like oh it's not going
to be here
they don't have anything yeah
okay
nice buildings
well
this concert
i
first
uh
yes
it was originally
called subway
you're looking
you're okay right
[Music]
short
okay
that's been
turned off okay
i am short if i ever stand in my toes
those that might be aimed at me
yeah apparently that's been pointed out
already and we've been told it can't be
changed
um
okay
testing one two testing or testing
testing
yes
yes
testing testing testing testing testing
this is only a test
everyone good on audio
good
good
good
you got it all good
is
test test test test this is merely a
test
it was not a test that would not be here
one two one two three four five
one two three four five
one two
is
good morning
oh
all right
oh yeah
oh
thank you
okay
he's a cacao
um
yes
foreign
hello
yes
you know i've heard
oh
i never
louder
three two one one two three
okay
yes
more likely
okay
abc
i haven't got an update yet
questions
yes
[Music]
all right we're going to test the audio
one more time how are me on my left
on my left news 12.
on my left okay on my right hand side
pix11 with the hashmarks you got me
thank you bill
is
is
yes
oh
okay
oh gosh
um
that's the best
oh
[Music]
are we differently
look
uh
yes
is
they
oh
um
okay
foreign
oh
oh
okay
yes
[Music]
um
i was like
so they don't have
is
you're gonna wipe down
yeah like overnight
it's one of those things
i mean
he's arrested
thanks that yeah
um
this is how it looks
you know like definitely out here
honestly
is
i forget what i did
workshops
technology is supposed to make
everything fast
huh
working on that
i haven't seen
please
yes
um
yes
yes
okay
[Music]
that's very great
is
looks like a lot
nobody worries
[Music]
yes
guys two minutes all right two minutes
sound check sound check
sound check
sound check sound check all right thank
you guys make sure your cell phones
aren't vibrating please
um
you know
[Music]
oh
he's looking out the window
right behind you
you guys
thank you
here you go
here we go
good evening i'm john miller deputy
commissioner for intelligence and
counterterrorism
we're here to provide an update on the
ongoing investigation into the shooting
that occurred earlier today in brooklyn
we're going to hear from police
commissioner of the city of new york
kishon sool
uh chief of department ken corey
first deputy commissioner ed caban here
chief of detectives james essig will
update us on the investigation
we also have
assistant director in charge of the fbi
in charge of the new york office mike
driscoll
and the jttf efforts with the nypd that
are ongoing as well as the special agent
in charge of the bureau of alcohol
tobacco and firearms uh john devito
but we'll begin with word from gracie
mansion from the mayor of the city of
new york eric adams
he's talking but we cannot hear the
mayor
so
thank you all for your patience
uh we're having an audio difficulty so
what we're going to do is regroup here
we're going to talk to the police
commissioner
thank you all for attending this evening
and helping us get this information out
to the public it's so important
we are truly fortunate that this was not
significantly worse than it is
as we reported this afternoon a man who
was traveling on a manhattan-bound n
train
opened two canisters that dispensed
smoke throughout the subway car
he then shot multiple passengers as the
train pulled into the 36th street
station in sunset park
10 people were injured by gunfire and an
additional 13 were either injured as
they rushed to get out of the train
station or they suffered smoke
inhalation
some good news is that none of the
injuries appear to be life-threatening
as detectives processed the crime scene
they recovered a nine millimeter
semi-automatic handgun
extended magazines and a hatchet
also found is a liquid we believe to be
gasoline
and a bag containing consumer grade
fireworks and a hobby fuse
about an hour ago detectives located a
u-haul van in brooklyn that we believe
is connected to the suspect
at this time we still do not know the
suspect's motivation
clearly this individual boarded the
train and was intent on violence
we are conducting a highly coordinated
investigation that includes nypd
detectives
the fbi nypd joint terrorism task force
and the atf who have been instrumental
in tracing the firearm and ballistics
the suspect is a dark-skinned male and
was wearing a neon orange vest and a
gray colored sweatshirt
we do have a person of interest in this
investigation
but we need the public assistance with
additional
we're asking anyone with information to
call crime stoppers at 800 577 tips
we know this incident is of grave
concern to new yorkers
we cannot lose sight of victims in this
city
we will use every resource we can to
bring those to justice who continue to
prey on the citizens of new york
i'll ask chief james essec to come in
and give details of the investigation
good evening everybody
today at 8 24 a.m
i bought a manhattan-bound n train 10
people were shot
seven males three females and they were
removed to area hospitals
an additional 13 people suffered
injuries related to smoke
inhalation falling down
or a panic attack
the information i'm about to give you is
preliminary and it's subject to change
right now
as that n train was between stations
59th street and the 36th street stations
seated in the second car
and the rear corner was a dark skinned
male
various descriptions of his height are
given he is heavy set
wearing an orange green nylon type
construction vest
he also had on a gray hoodie a surgical
mask
and a neon green construction helmet
as the train approached the 36th street
station witnesses state
the mail opened up two smoke grenades
tossed them on the subway floor
brandishes a glock nine millimeter
handgun he then fired that weapon at
least 33 times striking 10 people
the male then fled the scene and
detectives are actively trying to
determine his whereabouts
recovered at that scene
was a glock 17 nine millimeter handgun
three extended glock type magazines
one was still in the weapon
one under a seat and one in a backpack
we had 33 discharge shell casings
15 bullets
five bullet fragments
two detonated smoke grenades
two non-detonated smoke grenades
a hatchet a black garbage can
a black milk tire type style rolling
cart
the gasoline
and a u-haul key
the u-haul key at the scene led us to
the recovery of a u-haul van a short
while ago in brooklyn
the male who we believe is the renter of
this u-haul in philadelphia
is a frank r james
male 62 years old with addresses in
wisconsin and philadelphia
we are endeavoring to locate him to
determine his connection to the subway
shooting if any
the two crime scenes the subway and the
van
are very active and are still being
processed
we are asking for anyone's help with
information
cell phone video
witness information or any if they can
identify the perpetrator or the renter
of this vehicle to call crime stop visit
1-800-577 tips
there is a 50 000 reward out right now
25 000 from the new york city police
foundation
12 500 from the mta and 12 500 from the
twa local 100.
i just want to assure everyone that we
in the nypd have all our resources
working this along with our partners in
the fbi and the atf to find this
perpetrator
with that i'd like to turn it over to
mike driscoll
[Music]
mr mayor we're ready for you
thank you uh commissioner and
[Music]
and chief
as we indicated that today was a
difficult day for new york
days like these are planned out too
often in cities across america
as mentioned this morning it was just an
act of violence and evil
in the heart of brooklyn
where shooter attacked a subway car full
of innocent people at the 36th street
station
we saw a quiet tuesday morning turned
the m-train into a war zone as a small
bomb was dedicated and multiple shots
rang out
we witnessed 20 individuals
so far as it was mentioned
that thanks to the quick thinking of the
mta crew and the bravery and cooperation
of passengers lives were saved
then thanks to our first responders the
injuries were quickly taken to area
hospitals and all of them are expected
to recover
you know i have been realistic and
outspoken about my commitment to
protecting public safety i stand by that
and will continue to do everything in my
power to damn the rivers that feed the
sea of violence
but this is not only a new york city
problem
this rage this violence these guns these
relentless shooters are an american
problem
it is going to take all levels of
government to solve it
it is going to take the entire nation to
speak out and push back against the cult
of death that has taken hold in this
nation
a cult that allows innocence to be
sacrificed on a daily basis
a country where buying weapons of mass
destruction is as easy as picking up a
piece of plywood or garden shovel
a country where there are more guns than
people there are over 400 million guns
in this country alone
the u.s gun homicide rate is 26 times
that of other high-income countries
where over 100 people die in gun vines
every day
guns are the leading cause of death for
american children and teens
like the 16 year old baby we should lost
in the bronx
from schools in colorado sandy hook and
virginia to music festivals in las vegas
to nightclubs in orlando to movie
theaters and yoga classes across the
nation
these killers have used weapons of mass
destruction to massacre innocent people
they control no armies or military
forces yet these individual killers
terrorize our nation
i've often said
that this city is not going to adapt to
dysfunction ending gun violence means
changing gun laws we cannot clean up a
flood when the water is still pouring
into the basement
and we can never stop the killing if we
cannot stop the guns to be clear
we will not surrender our city to the
violent view
and we will not surrender all of america
to this cult of death the sea of
violence comes from many rivers we must
damn every river that feeds the greater
crisis that is the work of my life
this administration and this police
survivor i will not stop until the peace
we deserve becomes the reality we
experience you have my word as a former
police officer a fellow new yorker and
your mayor and we will end this epidemic
and that will capture the individual
responsible for today's attack we will
capture him and prosecute him to the
full extent of the law
thank you nypd fdmy our first responders
the collaboration from the federal
government the state and city agencies
thank you mr mayor i'd like to turn it
over to assistant special agent in
charge of the fbi new york office
michael driscoll
thank you commissioner
i want to start by expressing
our hopes and prayers that the victims
of this event
will enjoy a quick recovery
they are our primary focus right now
i also want to echo the thanks for the
partnership to the nypd
the atf and all the partners who are
contributing to this investigation right
now the fbi nypd joint terrorism task
force is fully engaged with this
investigation providing assistance
through manpower technical assistance
and basically everything we can throw at
it
we expect the process to be a long one
as we gather all possible information to
track down all possible leads and i
would encourage you as i was mentioned
earlier to please reach out to the nypd
tip line at 1-800-577-tips
and i would also add as frequently the
case in many
of our current investigations uh
everyone's got a cell phone in their
pocket there's a lot of video out there
if you have digital information that
you'd like to share with with us in
connection with this investigation
please visit fbi.gov brooklyn shooting
where you can upload that information
so we are seeking the public's help you
heard mentioned before of a name of
possible interest
videos would be particularly helpful or
any other additional witnesses who have
yet to come forward that can provide
information
that might help this investigation so
thank you for your participation and i
thank everyone for their partnership in
the course of the investigation thank
you
take a couple questions
we are not sure where he went at this
point at a subject to investigation we
have a number of resources that are
combing on foot and doing video campuses
as well to determine where he went
post
you posted videos online talking about
being addicted
to the mayor's mental health program
so based on some preliminary information
there are some postings possibly
connected to our person of interest
where he mentions homelessness he
mentions new york and he does mention
mayor adams and as a result of that an
abundance of caution we're going to
tighten their security detail
just to be clear
he's not the person of interest that is
in custody at this moment
have no one in custody at this time
no we are looking for frank james we
know he rented this u-haul van
the key of that u-haul van was found at
the crime scene in the
those social subway posts
we're pouring through that but yes
correct
is that correct
we are
looking to determine if he has any
connection to the train
we know mr james rented that u-haul
truck in philadelphia
[Music]
so we're not calling them threats he
made some concerning posts or someone
made some concerning posts we cannot
attribute it to that individual yet
that's not an investigation but again in
an abundance of caution we're going to
tighten the mayor's security detail
that's all
that is subject to investigation we
don't have that information yet
mr james is just a person of interest we
know right now who rented that u-haul
van in philadelphia the keys to that
u-haul van were found in the subway
in our shooter's possessions we don't
know right now if mr james has any
connection to the subway that's still
under investigation
the crime scene still being processed
now the van is being processed and the
subway crime scene is being processed
but we it's too early right now to tell
city kate um can you explain where this
new hall was located was it nearby and
then also um when he said um you're
investigating these videos but can you
confirm that it was him in the video or
people that knows that we're just trying
the the video the youtube videos and the
videos onto there there's a man who
posts in there frank james we're still
working to see if that's our person who
rented the video
and where were you all located uh kings
highway in brooklyn
30
west 4th and king's highway
there were general topics of concern and
i don't want to go into too many details
about the mayor's security detail we're
just doing it uh just to be on the safe
side
complaints about homelessness complaints
about new york nothing in general i'm
sorry just general comments that caused
us some concern that are subject to
investigation at this point
why were there no working surveillance
cameras in the station why did police
radios not work in the station and how
much did those factors have for this
investigation
yeah we know that there were three
stations that the video wasn't working
we're still
investigating that to see why or how
those uh whether it was a mechanical
problem electrical issue why those
videos weren't up
there was no issues with police radios
yeah so
patrol officers
so officers who work
top side if you will in patrol precincts
when they go down the station they have
to switch frequencies it's a uhf versus
vhf so if they didn't switch the radio
over to the u to the vhf frequency they
would not be able to transmit down in
the subway station so it's user error it
wasn't a problem with the actual
radio how many officers are assigned to
the 36th street station and were there
any officers in the station at all
so we don't typically assign officers to
subway stations officers patrol on a
rotating basis they ride trains they
come out they patrol the stations
officers from the precinct stop go down
they do station inspections we've been
doing that since january so that that
station was patrolled several times
today there were no officers present in
the station
at the time of the shooting but it had
been patrolled several times on this
calendar date prior to the shooting in
the early morning hours
what do we know about mr james and his
local ties in new york city
tim
we know mr james mr james has addresses
in wisconsin
and
philadelphia
as far as new york still under
investigation but he's just a person of
interest right now in this case
we know the shooter
was was entered the station on king's
highway
so we're asking for anybody who knows
from king's highway to 35th street is
eight stops anybody who sees him with
any information please call
crimestoppers
we literally have hundreds of detectives
out in the field right now pouring
through video at train stations the
egresses
the recovery sites of the vehicle
so we hope to have clearer pictures of
who we believe is the shooter
as far as pulling the trigger that's
still under investigation as far as the
firearm is concerned we know it's not
part of a multi-cell we know it's not
stolen we're working with our partners
in the atf to track back to the point of
sale and then move forward on that gun
last question
your physical description of james
doesn't match the descriptions
again as i said we there was two smoke
grenades thrown we have various
descriptions of height i gave the
description out of the man with the vest
we're looking through all
all possible leads on our personal
events i think if you look at our social
media you'll see two photos
all right thank you very much
did their own job
yes
you